ab heute heißt es aus für einweg plastik
das bleibt die frage nach guten
alternativen corona impfen ja oder nein
unter 18-jährige und ihre eltern werden
mit ihrer entscheidung auf die allein
gelassen
sommer sonne lebensgefahr beim schwimmen
an seen und flüssen ereignen sich immer
wieder tödliche badeunfälle
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg haben schön dass sie
dabei sind wie auch norbert könig für
den sport ja hallo und genannt einweg
plastikprodukte wie strohhalme becher
oder auch wattestäbchen sind ein
riesenproblem für die umwelt den der eu
machen sie 70 prozent des gesamten
meeres mülls aus damit dass weniger wird
ist plastische und co ab heute eu weit
verboten
gerade deutschland hat einiges
aufzuholen christoph distel in
deutschland ist europameister beim
plastikmüll
statistisch kommt jeder deutsche auf 228
kilogramm pro jahr mit trennen und
recyceln ist das problem einigermaßen im
griff könnte man meinen
tatsächlich aber wird mehr als die
hälfte unseres plastikmülls verbrannt
wie der verwertung ist kompliziert und
teuer hierzulande teurer als neue
kunststoff produkte oft wird deutscher
plastikmüll daher in billiglohnländer
wie malaysia verschickt auch das gilt
als recyceln egal was mit dem müll dort
passiert damit ist deutschland teil
eines globalen problems weltweit
gelangen jedes jahr etwa 10 bis 20
millionen tonnen plastik in die umwelt
an land und rund noch mal so viel in die
meere eine plastikflasche zum beispiel
zersetzt sich dort erst nach mehreren
jahrhunderten
der gigantische plastikmüll strudel im
nordpazifik ist nur eines der
sichtbarsten alarmzeichen deutlich
größer als deutschland
inzwischen findet sich weltweit das
plastik des menschen an den entlegensten
stellen von der arktis bis runter in den
marianengraben vögel und meeressäuger
verwechseln die kleinteile mit nahrung
und verhungern dann trotz vollem magen
andere folgen für artenvielfalt und
klima kann noch niemand abschätzen auch
nicht die für den menschen wenn das
mikro plastik über die nahrungskette
wieder zu ihm zurück kommt erster hilfe
soll jetzt also das verbot von einweg
plastik bieten doch wie so oft steckt
auch hier die tücke im detail elisabeth
schmid dieses vietnamesische restaurant
in hannover ist schon umgestiegen beim
take away kommenden sommer rollen glas
nudelsalat und curry schon seit
jahresbeginn nicht mehr in plastik für
und andere deckel sollen auch bald her
ab heute sind in der eu plastikprodukte
wie to go becher und einweggeschirr
fastfood behälter trinkhalme rühr und
wattestäbchen verboten
restbestände dürfen noch aufgebraucht
werden der markt für plastik
alternativen ist allerdings noch
überschaubar das erlebt auch
restaurantchef an
für die kunden soll es trotzdem nicht
merklich teurer werden ergab eine
umfrage der verbraucherzentrale
sie begrüßen das plastik verbot das ist
ein guter schritt weil er zum einen eben
eine starke signalwirkung hat er wurde
von den verbrauchern sehr gut
aufgenommen weil man gesehen hat die
politik versucht hier zu handeln
umweltschützer sehen in den einweg
alternativen dagegen nur eine
zwischenlösung
das macht überhaupt keinen sinn ein weg
durch ein weg zu ersetzen also wenn sie
vorher einen blick plastik hat hatten
und jetzt komm essens boxen oder becher
aus palmenblättern oder noch schlimmer
aus aluminium als einweg produkt dann
ist dadurch nichts gewonnen kein gramm
abfall fällt weniger am auf lange sicht
seien mehrwegbehälter für kaffee und
speisen besser ab 2023 müssen
restaurants und lieferdienste in
deutschland diese ihren kunden zumindest
anbieten was bringt das verbot von
einweg- plastik einen faktencheck dazu
finden sie auf zdf heute.de und in
unserer app außerdem informationen
welche alternativen es gibt
zum thema corona darstellt die neue
empfehlung der ständigen impfkommission
die hausärzte vor eine logistische
herausforderung viele patienten wollten
ihre zweitimpfung vorziehen sagt der
verband seit donnerstag empfiehlt die
stiko die kreuz impfung wer eine erste
spritze astrazeneca bekommen hat soll
danach bei ihren tag oder moderner
kriegen die korona zahlen bleiben auf
niedrigem niveau das robert koch
institut meldet 671 neuinfektionen
binnen 24 stunden
sich mehr als vergangenen samstag 16
todesfälle kamen innerhalb eines tages
dazu die sieben tage incidents sinkt auf
4,9 und ist so niedrig wie das seit fast
einem jahr nicht mehr
soll ich mein kind gegen korona impfen
lassen diese frage treibt viele eltern
um für kinder unter zwölf gibt es
derzeit noch gar keinen zugelassenen
impfstoff eine impfung für über
zwölfjährige empfiehlt die ständige
impfkommission bislang nur unter
bestimmten bedingungen zum beispiel bei
vorerkrankungen einige ärzte dagegen
raten zum impfen und bieten es auch an
sibylle bassler und patricia schäfer
hier gibt es was woanders kaum zu
bekommen ist corona impfungen auch für
kinder und jugendliche ab zwölf die
hausarztpraxis im bayerischen neu-ulm
zieht menschen aus ganz deutschland an
so wie diese familie aus kassel
verunsichert natürlich als alter haben
jetzt aber dort trotzdem gesorgt wir
machen was so schlimm finde ich jetzt
nicht also ich finds besser als jetzt
corona zu machen seit juni ist der neue
ulmer hausarzt auch unter 18-jährige mit
den älteren jahrgängen ist er schon
durch er sagt die stiko rate auch nicht
ab von der impfung für kinder
tatsächlich gibt es nur keine allgemeine
empfehlung für kinder ohne
vorerkrankungen arabische liga hat ganz
klar gesagt man soll ab dem zwölften
lebensjahr sogar dringend empfohlen
gerade in bezug auf die delta variante
und auch die american heart association
also die amerikanische herzgesellschaft
ganz klar dieses thema mit den
herzmuskel gelungen ist eher
vernachlässigbar weil die treten zwar
auf sind aber alles sehr mild und sehr
harmlos im verlauf in den usa wurden
bereits knapp 30 millionen zwölf- bis
18-jährige geimpft seit mai bis etwaige
komplikationen auftreten dauert es
jedoch bis zu zwei monate deshalb will
der münchner kinder infektiologie
johannes hübner noch abwarten das
wichtigste was wir tun können ist dass
wir die erwachsene bevölkerung soweit
wie möglich durch impfen
die erwachsenen stellen auch einen
schutz für die kinder da wenn wir wie in
israel 60 70 prozent der bevölkerung
doppelt geimpft haben dann gehen auch
die infektionszahlen bei den kindern so
zurück das wird ihnen kinder im moment
auf jeden fall gar nicht impfen brauchen
doch die nachfrage ist groß heute haben
sie in der praxis von dr grüner fast 400
dosen verimpft an kinder und erwachsene
in afrika sind weniger als zwei prozent
der menschen gegen korona geimpft
dort breitet sich aktuell die pandemie
schneller und mächtiger aus als je zuvor
auch wegen der delta variante besonders
betroffen ist südafrika hier gibt es
einen höchststand der korona
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden wurden
mehr als 24.000 neue fälle gemeldet der
vize gesundheitsminister mahnt das land
befinde sich im auge des sturms es geht
nun wieder strengere lockdown regeln
sandra times berichtet doctorow ag
arbeitet im kotflügel einer klinik in
kriegsdorf die dritte welle trifft
südafrika härter als die vorherigen
getrieben von der delta variante es
fehlt an intensivbetten und
beatmungsgeräte das medizinische
personal ist völlig überlastet
ich bin erschöpft sagt die ärztin
physisch aber auch emotional
wir haben das sterben in diesem ausmaß
noch nicht gesehen
in der ausbildung sagt man ihr das ein
paar patienten sterben werden
aber es ist nicht normal sie in diesen
raten sterben zusehen
offiziell starben in südafrika mehr als
61.000 menschen am virus
die dunkelziffer ist deutlich höher seit
dieser woche gelten schärfere lockdown
regeln
hart trifft es die gastronomie
restaurants müssen schließen essen darf
nur noch geliefert werden
beim ersten login kamen die leute noch
und haben essen zum mitnehmen geholt
aber jetzt kommt kaum einer
die menschen haben große angst im moment
doch ansonsten ist fast alles offen ob
industrie oder einzelhandel die
wirtschaft läuft es ist ein halbherziger
lockdown wenn südafrika kann sich einen
haken london wirtschaftlich nicht
leisten
vor gut einem jahr gingen dabei
millionen jobs verloren und die
jung will verhindern dass sich das
wiederholt das problem ist dass die
jetzigen maßnahmen wohl kaum ausreichen
dürften um diese welle in den griff zu
kriegen
auch beim thema impfen sieht es düster
aus
nicht einmal ein prozent der
südafrikaner hat vollen impfschutz in
den osten afrikas nach äthiopien in der
krisenregion t3 warnen die vereinten
nationen vor einer hungerkatastrophe
inzwischen haben integral mehr als
400.000 menschen nicht mehr genug zu
essen so un-mitarbeiter 33.000 kinder
sind schwer unterernährt weitere 1,8
millionen menschen von hunger bedroht
integra gibt es seit monaten kämpfe
zwischen der äthiopischen armee und
aufständischen
hunderttausende menschen wurden
vertrieben zurück nach deutschland
der bund zahlt jährlich mehr als 50
millionen euro an ehemalige abgeordnete
eine zusatzrente die nicht mehr
zeitgemäß sei heißt es in einer
gemeinsamen erklärung von
parlamentariern verschiedener parteien
abgeordnete müssten selbst für ihr alter
vorsorgen
ihr vorschlag der neu gewählte bundestag
solle eine reform der pensionsansprüche
in angriff nehmen wenn es draußen so
heiß ist dann wächst mit der lust auf
schnelle abkühlung leider auch das
risiko fast täglich ereignen sich
schwere badeunfälle weil viele
schwimmbäder geschlossen haben oder
wegen krone nur begrenzt badegäste
einlassen nutzen immer mehr menschen
seen und flüsse zur abkühlung
doch immer weniger können wirklich gut
schwimmen mail ist hier ja berichtet die
buchten am rhein laden viele menschen
dazu einmal den fuß ins wasser zu
stecken manche trauen sich sogar zu
schwimmen
doch das kann schnell zu einer großen
gefahr werden 2020 sind deutschlandweit
mindestens 378 personen ertrunken und
auch in diesem jahr gab es schon viele
tote die gründe dafür sind vielfältig
wir haben jetzt schon eine generation
heranwachsende und junge erwachsene hat
die schon keine starken schlimmer sind
aufgrund der bäder schließung und der
prekären lage das eben das auch in den
schulen schon nicht mehr gut vermittelt
werden kann durch corona kommt jetzt
mindestens eine generation hinzu die
eben auch nicht schwimmen gelernt hat
hinzu kommt dann noch ein jahr lang
nicht schwimmen trainieren ansehen kann
schon ein kälteschock zum tod führen an
flüssen sind gefährliche strömungen der
grund für badeunfälle selbst geübte
schwimmer innen können durch den sog bis
auf den grund gezogen werden
die starken strömungen entstehen meist
durch schiffe die innerhalb kürzester
zeit eine art ebbe und flut verursachen
können wo kinder tatsächlich 34 meter
von der uferlinie weg im flachen wasser
spielen
die aufsichts berechtigten die eltern im
hintergrund zeitunglesen kaffee trinken
was auch immer machen und dann kommen
die schiffe vorbei und diese strömung
die dann entsteht führt dazu dass sie
selbst wenn sie unmittelbar daneben sind
34 meter weg ihr kind nicht mehr greifen
können muss noch zu retten
auch wenn es offiziell nicht überall
verboten ist vor allem baden in flüssen
kann lebensgefährlich sein nachfolger in
miami haben die behörden nach dem
teileinsturz eines hochhauses ein
weiteres appartement gebäude evakuiert
laut stadtverwaltung sind struktur und
elektrik in dem gebäude in not miami
beach und sicher unterdessen stieg die
zahl der opfer ins offside auf 24 noch
immer suchen helfer nach weiteren
verschütteten
teile des gebäudes waren von neun tagen
aus noch ungeklärter ursache eingestürzt
der rest des hauses soll morgen
abgerissen werden
heftige regenfälle haben in japan
schwere überschwemmungen und erdrutsche
ausgelöst in der küstenstadt atami
südwestlich von tokio bis eine
schlammlawine mehrere wohnhäuser mit
sich etwa 20 menschen werden noch
vermisst
die behörden riefen zehntausende
menschen auf sich in sicherheit zu
bringen
infolge der globalen klimaerwärmung
verzeichnet japan
starke regenfälle und immer häufiger
auch erdrutsche und jetzt fußball der
das erste halbfinale der
europameisterschaft steht fest in
italien gegen spanien könnte auch ein
endspiel könnte auch ein endspiel sein
und wenn dann wäre es mit den italienern
als favoriten jetzt aber schon in der
vorschlussrunde
dann werden sich die spanier gegen zehn
schweizer nur mühevoll im
elfmeterschießen durchsetzen haben die
italiener gegen belgien ihre ansprüche
untermauert 53 jahre nach ihrem einzigen
em-titel endlich wieder europas beste zu
werden
die fans in der römischen heimat im
freudentaumel nach dem schlusspfiff des
bisher wohl besten spiels dieser em
beide teams mit richtig guten
gelegenheiten in der 31 minute gegen
italien durch nicolo varela in führung
richtig sehenswert das 2 0 ein
herrlicher schlenzer von lorenzo
inszeniert italien in allen belangen auf
höchstem niveau
nach einem schubser von di lorenzo gegen
doku kam belgien noch in der ersten
hälfte zum anschlusstreffer elfmeter
romelo lukaku verwandelte zum 2 2 1 der
ausgleich gelang nicht mehr italien seit
32 länderspielen ungeschlagen
wir haben verdient gewonnen die jungs
waren wirklich außergewöhnlich im
halbfinale wartet jetzt spanien auf den
em favoriten italien ein sieg fehlt noch
dann dürfen deutschlands bester
basketballer zu den olympischen spielen
nach tokio reisen nach dem 86 76 gegen
gastgeber kroatien geht es morgen im
finale des qualifikationsturniers gegen
brasilien um alles oder nichts
alexander zverev präsentiert sich weiter
stark auf dem rasen von wimbledon nach
dem viersatz erfolg gegen taylor fritz
aus den usa das achtelfinale erreicht
genau wie bei den frauen angelique
kerber das drittrunden match beginnt für
angelique kerber gegen die bieler russin
alexandra sassnitz mit einem fehlstart
sie verliert ihre beiden ersten
aufschlagspiele beim stand von 1 zu 5
dann eine regenpause wie die wende zum
guten bringen
ich habe ein bisschen zu langsam
angefangen im ersten satz und im zweiten
satz nach der regenpause
habe ich das spiel selber in die hand
genommen das war dann auch der schlüssel
zum erfolg nach gut eineinhalb stunden
unterbrechung verliert kerber den ersten
satz noch mit 2 26
im zweiten spiel sie aggressiv setzt
sadovic unter druck gewinnt mit 6 zu 0
kerber dominiert weiter verwandelt im
dritten satz den ersten matchball zum 6
2 1 im achtelfinale spielt sie gegen die
17-jährige kauf aus den usa
vorjahressieger tadday poker hat auf der
ersten alpenetappe der tour de france
seine schärfsten konkurrenten deutlich
distanziert der slowene überquerte die
ziellinie zwar nur als vierter beim sieg
des belgiers dylan fans hat aber jetzt
als neuer träger des gelben trikots eine
minute und 48 sekunden vorsprung auf den
einzigen ernsthaften verfolger lockern
als das war ich danke dir wie aufregend
einen museumsbesuch sein kann zeigt sich
in paris im naturkundemuseum dort muss
man mit ungewöhnlichen besuchern rechnen
ganz offensichtlich bleiben hier nicht
alle tiere hinter glas
[Musik]
zum glück sind diese entfernten
verwandten einer serie virtuelle
exemplare die 3d ausstellung lässt
längst ausgestorbene arten wieder
aufleben
zumindest in den augen der besucher neue
gewitter kündigen sich an und auch
unwetter sind dabei mehr dazu gleich von
osten terli marietta slomka freut sich
auf sie im heute journal um viertel nach
elf danke für ihr interesse
machen sie sich noch ein schönes
wochenende und bis morgen wenn sie mögen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter das kleine hoch
jedes verabschiedet sich allmählich nach
südosten von westen her erreicht uns
aber eine front mit zahlreichen schauern
und gewittern
das wird dann morgen im tagesverlauf der
fall sein
schauen wir erst einmal in die nacht da
gibt es vom tag noch schauer und
gewitter vor allem in den westlichen
landesteilen die werden allmählich
nachlassen ansonsten ist es eher locker
bewölkt bei temperaturen bis 10 grad in
schleswig holstein und 15 bis 17 grad in
den westlichen landesteilen ja und
morgen zunächst einmal auch im westen
sonniges wetter und dann zieht es
relativ rasch zu schauer und gewitter
mit starkregen und hagel sind durchaus
möglich
man kann es auch zu unwettern kommen
allerdings wird es wohl nicht ganz so
krass sein wie in den vergangenen wochen
den östlichen landesteilen scheint
häufiger die sonne bei temperaturen dort
bis 28 grad und 20 grad richtung eifel
die kommenden tage
am montag gibt es im osten und im norden
schauer und gewitter bis 25 grad
dienstag wird es bis 30 grad heiß und
mittwoch ist vor allem im süden schauer
sind schauer angesagt damit ein schöner
abend